[Music]
we have all lied before but no one likes
being lied to this is why we wish that
we could have a lie detector with us to
really know what people are hiding but
you'll be happy to hear that your eyes
and your ears are all it takes to spot a
liar unless they heard about some of our
tricks make sure you watch this video
until the end to know how you can become
a good liar if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe to the things and please give
this video a big thumbs up today we're
showing you five foolproof ways to spot
a liar The Voice don't listen to what
people are saying but pay attention to
how they say it instead you will notice
that their voice changes when they're
lying they might be talking faster or
slower than they usually do the tension
can also cause a change in pitch like a
rise or a fallen pitch most of the time
that's because they're playing a role
and hiding their nerve ASSA tea is what
makes them look less natural however you
need to know them to see the difference
but there are also some things you can
notice if you're talking to a stranger
they might tend to stutter or stammer
more than people usually do if they feel
stressed you'll also notice that they
hesitate a lot for example if you've
ever watched a videotaped interrogation
of a suspect who turned out to be guilty
you will often see that it becomes more
difficult for them to speak that's
because the automatic nervous system
decreases salivary flow when someone
feels stressed and there is no way they
can hide it ask as many questions as you
want so they will feel uncomfortable and
this is how you're going to come closer
to the truth but if you want to know
what else the mouth and the language can
say about a liar you will have to watch
this video until the end the eyes many
people say that the eyes don't lie and
it is by looking at them that you will
uncover the truth take a look at their
eye movements people might think that
people who lie will avoid looking at you
because they know that they're doing
something bad but if they know that they
might try to cheat and stare at you to
make sure that you trust them this is a
way for them to manipulate and control
you however this is something that you
can notice too as it will look really
unnatural they probably also won't blink
at regular intervals if they don't stare
at you you can also pay attention to
where they are looking if they're trying
to remember something they will usually
look to the left but
they're making something up they will
look to the right and there is also one
thing you can look for that is really
important because they don't have any
control over it their pupil might dilate
if they're telling a lie however you
should take a look at other people's
eyes because it might only be caused by
lighting if they put their hand or their
fingers in their eye it might be a way
for them to hide the truth so you should
not trust them however you can't know
that someone is lying only by looking at
their eyes and this is why you should
pay attention to other details the body
what you see can tell much more than
what you hear this is why you want to
look at their body language if you ask
them a direct question their head will
probably make a sudden movement if they
are lying about something their
breathing will also change and you will
see their shoulders rise it is a reflex
action when someone is stressed because
of their lie because their heart rate
and blood flow changes you could also
notice them fidgeting because they are
nervous shuffling their feet could not
only show that they feel stressed but
also that they want to walk away because
they feel uncomfortable not moving at
all could also be a bad sign because
everyone reacts differently to stress
anyway as soon as you see something that
looks unnatural it might not be a good
sign they will also cover vulnerable
parts of their body like their throat
their chest their head or their abdomen
this is what people usually do when they
feel threatened or vulnerable however if
they are defensive you might see a lot
of pointing because they want to turn
the tables on you because you discovered
their lives there are so many things
that we need to remember now we
understand why detectives videotape
interrogations there are way too many
things that they need to look for during
a simple conversation the mouth the
truth will always come from someone's
mouth even if it's not with their words
that's because this body part can say a
lot of things that you won't only here
but also see once again if someone
covers their mouth it might be a sign
that they don't want to deal with an
issue or a question because they don't
want you to see the truth it's just like
they want to cover the lies that they're
saying but what are they hiding if they
feel nervous you will see a lot of
throat clearing and swallowing they will
also bite or lick their lips this could
be a sign that they are tense which
indicates distress a smile and laughing
could also be a bad sign in
inappropriate situations that's because
it shows that they feel uncomfortable
and that they don't know what to do
someone who is not lying would take this
seriously having dead
chuckle tea speaking is something that
they won't be able to avoid if they feel
stressed because nervosa tea will make
them produce less saliva which will dry
out the mucous membranes of the mouth
anyway don't stare at their mouth too
much because it might look weird and
there are many other things that you
don't want to miss the arms if you're
lying the most important things that
will betray you are your arms
liars keep thinking about the eyes and
how to control their movement but the
truth might be hiding a little below we
heard about people hiding their mouth or
some vulnerable parts of their body with
their arms these are all signs that they
are hiding something from you and they
feel threatened when you want to know
the truth but there are also many other
things that the arms of a liar can say
excessive hand gesture is usually a sign
that someone is not telling the truth
they're not only feeling nervous but
they also feel like they need to do more
to prove something but there is also a
little test that you can do and use it
as a lie detector ask the suspect to
extend their arms straight out in front
of them and tell them that you're going
to push it down well they should try to
keep their arm up then ask them to tell
their story and push on their arm if
they are lying
you should feel less resistant than when
they're telling the truth this is
because their brain is working harder
when they're telling a lie and it makes
it harder to perform small physical
tasks however we don't know if the
suspect is going to trust you if you ask
them to do this little test and that's
it for five foolproof ways to spot a
liar for more stories like this make
sure you watch 10 ways you can survive a
plane crash thanks for watching
[Music]